okay so Frank Cullotta Frank you're you
grew up in Chicago that's correct
and your involvement with the Chicago
mob which is which was called the outfit
Chicago so we refer to it as the outfit
you know and your father had a similar
kind of pack as you right my father you
know he never wanted to be a gangster he
was a he was a thief he was a killer um
I was all of them things but he never
wanted to be controlled by any
organization like to you back then it
would have been the syndicate or the
outfit right and tell me about your
childhood you grew up with a mom and dad
yeah I grew up at a sister she was five
years older than me
mm-hm my mother was nine months pregnant
when my brother or my father died so my
brother never got to meet his father
come on and she was a very good mother
at least I know everybody thinks their
mother's the best well I feel as though
my mother was the best yeah
woman visited me every danger every
Sunday in jail for as many years as I
did since I was a kid
let's bring would tell me about your
father my father was it was not a bank
robber but he would do it I guess he did
a lot of robberies and burglaries he was
more or less a good wheelman getaway
driver that's what his reputation was
how I knew all of his stuff was because
of relatives you should tell me as I was
growing up in his friends my father's
friends otherwise they wouldn't knowing
that stuff I just do my father when I
was a kid had a violent temper and he
was very providing for the house I'm
very good
he hollered and my mother
he was very jealous but very much in
love mm-hmm and I love my father
that is the I still love him he's our
telling him that explains a lot of it
right he died in an automobile accident
he was killed he was being pursued by
the police because he had begged um they
used to come gas stamps rationing stamps
and he had a carload of him he was that
he just had sent but sunstate years in
Des Moines Iowa because he got caught
out there I think he was set up
so he was out on some type of an appeal
by them and he had more of these stamps
in his car and he took off and he was he
got killed in the car car accident hmm
and there's there's a connection between
your father and so you so you met Tony
Scott who is infamous Chicago mobster
when you guys were kids I guess Tony's
flight rowing myself
men at a very young age I am assuming it
was about 12 years old or maybe 11 him
somewhere around has been a long time
but it was round there and my mother
finally sent me on she says you got a
start you know you don't go make money
here's the shoebox make a shoebox so I
made a shoebox true shame bags because I
was stealing out of paper bags before
then I was climbing up the pole and
reached an end the bag grabbing nickels
out and run and finally the guy start
chasing that's how he sold newspapers
back then newspaper yeah there are
newspapers it was on your honor you drop
a nickel in and take a paper on well I
drop my hand in and took all the money
out there so I you know finally start
chasing me so that's when I start
signing shoes and the main street in
Chicago down
I've been up and down all my life is the
street called Grand Avenue so I'm on one
side of the street and there a voice
yelling at me you're in my territory get
out of here
another could cross the street and they
see it get his little shirt and a me so
he starts walking towards me I walk
towards him he says to me this is my
territory you need to get out of there
or I'll bust your head and I look up at
the street saying and I said I don't see
your name what's your name
it needs to supply Joe I said I'll see
her name in a street sign and I'll be
back here tomorrow they said well when I
come back tomorrow busting your head
I'll be back
so the next day I come back the next day
I come back for a second there every day
for a week or two and I didn't see this
little guy with this bad attitude then
one day I heard hey cuz he had asked me
my name when we were arguing on the
streets what's your name and I thumped
Colada
Frank Cullotta so when I seen him after
a week or two he helped to me again and
we met in the street and had been a
little streetcars down so we stood Betty
tracks and he said I can ask you a
question what was your father's first
name and I said why hey I just need that
[ __ ] out they away I said was Joe or
Joseph he said well oh you and I are
going to be friends the rest of our
lives and I said why what's the reason
for that and he said my father
overheard me talking with my brothers
about it a guy was having a problem what
she had shining shoes to my territory
when he heard the name colada he says he
call me in the room and he said find out
if that boy's name is as that boy's
father's name is Joe he's because if it
is um
the best friends from now on because
this father saved my life
and that's what Tony told me in the
conversation and I said then I come to
find out what took place and I my father
saved
Tony's father's life on his father's
name was Patsy
Tony's Tony's father had a restaurant
I'm Brandon Ogden we've referred to that
as the old neighborhood
it's up Northwest so I was called
Patsy's restaurant and he was famous for
the sandwiches as meatball sandwiches
would I come to find out as my father
went in there like everybody else around
that area to get food and spend money
guess he told one day say Joe I'm having
a lot of problems with these grease
balls my father grease balls back then
meant to Blackie that's what's the only
thing around them there was no Al Capone
of no Tony Accardo
so my mother said what were they doing
to you Betty
Batsy and he said well they come in they
feel like they want to collect for me
every week taxes the stamp business
piece I can't afford at these I'm just a
little business manner my father so what
they they come in and I guess he told
him today my father says I'll be here
that day before they get her in your
back the kitchen do you usually bring
him in the kitchen when you give him
money he said yeah so my brother says
I'm sort of following whatever today was
he came in with two of his guys and they
waited in the kitchen so when this guy
come to collect money from Patsy
Bessie brought him into the kitchen well
they got him in the kitchen my father
good friends and a killer pensee wasn't
in the kitchen when they kill Patsy
walked out of the kitchen and then I
don't know how to dispose of his body
but that's what happened to this game
well the word got back to her boss
no brusquely just walked up and on the
streets putting black hands on doors and
he wanted to know who these guys were
there was afraid to go by Patsy's
because he didn't know if Betsy had any
more guys waiting for
so he started continuing his operation
around brain and Eichmann by putting
black hand they'd have a black he can
put on people's doors paper and people
would know at that month so happened to
be one day my mother come home and I was
running on our door and she took that
she's a Bella month so my father come on
she's Joe somebody left this thing in
the dark well he went Gracie and he you
know and then he found out where this
guy went for the boss but it happened to
be his underboss the bosses under was
pushed for a haircut and he caught him
in the barber shop and he killed him in
a barber shop then he thought them soft
for this is what I know when I was told
she got to get the head of this guy's
out of the organization
somebody just and headed add
organization of black and win at night
he he took his wife for him and they
found out that he was on a boat tall
with his wife they kicked down a door
and he killed him in bed in front of his
wife that hurt his wife that was the end
of the black camp so then soon after
that the the outfit became you know Al
Capone and these guys so they wanted my
father to be involved and he don't want
to be able
II didn't want nothing to do with any
type of organization so that was
basically just erm I found it's a great
story so that that taped away for the
for the mob in Chicago in oh yeah sure I
guess yeah sure all Chicago see there's
the street in Chicago and most of these
guys they were connected
Al Capone lived on a street in Chicago
was called Taylor Street and that's
where it's called the 42 King come out
of them he serves forty two bosses forty
two guys over made money they come out
of that area Sam Giancana teeth tag
every like they're going on that but I'm
not doing and they all commented in
neighborhood although guys right now
they've been over a hundred some years
old and Tony Accardo Tony Accardo as a
matter of fact live in the house in
front of our house when I was afloat
child maybe four or five years old I
didn't Laura
he was probably not nobody back then I
like Sam Giancana I would always refer
to him as a man's man you so you've had
interactions with so many big and
powerful monsters from playing could go
on and on to the interaction I've had
[Music]
two or three that you think are
particularly interesting a walk he
filled I've
jax-ur own Willie Mussina tell me about
some of it when they were pointed to
these individuals personalities but
personnel well what made him what made
them unique and interesting
well there were all each wonderfully
unique in their own way you know Dale
had tempers there some of them were
nursing artistic narcissistic and some
were more just the nicest guys in the
world
so he had to be careful how you treated
each individual you know what they were
before he even got to meet him so if you
were a half smart
you know on a speaking arrangement yeah
nah Milwaukee Phil I always felt as
though he growled when he talked sandy
Stephano was a psychopath I worked for
him though
I've seen him in action definitely out
of his mind
Dietz Masari piece was wild too
Battaglia
James Thurber Elam
Turk like Turk I used to steal with Dirk
Dirk became a boss though Joe férula
become John ago great guy trust these
guys you're gonna get [ __ ] wank yeah
there's no doubt about it you were in
your way like I said I could go on all
day I meant Tony or Carol two times I
didn't talk to him in a Louisville where
he would be like my good buddy hey buddy
know that I respected this guy so much
anything he'd done because he was a
gentleman he never talked down to people
he knew I was when I was 18 years old
when I was 18 years old this guy knew
who I was shocked me but that set of
work travels the neck and that circle
when they know a guy's a tough guy or
he's capable they watch it what type
Tony or kuritomi
hey kid I know you are and I looked at
what's in a pancake house and it's who
are you sir
he's my name is Anthony ocurro and I saw
my god so pleasure to meet each I was
like shocked you know because they are
about and at that particular time Paul
Ricca was the boss today often Paul
Ricca was the boss for about 10 years so
it's just to me I know about you Frankie
he said you got a bad temper
Pacey's you go a long way he says if you
control your temper just some friendly
advice and by the way who are you
they won't know my friends are next to
me psyched ottoman the guys I love mr.
car and then the next time I had a stop
Woolley Mussina used to work for Gingka
I mean I'm sorry with a car go by he
stood do things to Ricardo themselves a
car really a monkey Tony a car had a
monkey so we're ruling Mussina was put
in charge than a monkey because the
monkey would therap the basement yeah
they might have stopped him pick up
something from Willie and Willie was
saying his [ __ ] monkeys I kill the
reason I could get away with it and
that's Tony come on
Tony Accardo come on and he looked at me
anyway they say Oh mr. Carl always mr.
Carl he's asked my monkey done Willie
Willie will shake yourself like that I
love lice I gotta get out of here but
that's that's the only two times I've
talked in a man tell me about Larry
Newman who was somebody you know Larry
Newman strange that you say that they
talked about a lot of fishes guys in the
off it and there were like a beach real
up a trail
his brother Jimmy vicious crazy bastard
scary gang I think Larry Newman was
worse did anyone had a worse they had in
the Alfa he was a Jewish guy I met him
in a penitentiary state Phil
penitentiaries Donal
[ __ ] a quarter of its honored 25
years for a triple murder he did 11 and
a half years on it
his father paid off the parole board mmm
his father was very wealthy so that's
where I met lefty we worked in an
assignment together with and I they call
it the detention high school they refer
to those cases the goon squad because we
would do with the guards didn't have the
ball so don't get crazy people out of
the cells and bring them to this
attention
detention house
where all the cycles were and that's who
we were watch there was eight of us so
we control that Florida Hospital you
know with the cycles and that's where I
met him and then Larry join me and later
years in Vegas but he was he was a
killer that took it was about he was a
killer but but he took it to another
level right I refer to Larry Newman as a
serial killer he enjoyed killing and to
make a different side culture if he had
to catch up with pieces to get rid do
that you know I mean the guy had he's
just an evil man he was an evil man he
died in the penitentiary he uh he went
back but I put him back in a
penitentiary because he testified amount
of murder he committed which he
shouldn't have committed so so
eventually you ended up doing some you
started off with some robberies like a
bank and Brinks trucks and slowly today
you did you made yeah oh yeah you gotta
start somewhere and I started out but
you started out being these were people
would not yeah well I got big quick I
was I had a car I bought with stocks and
bonds that my father loved so what's an
Oldsmobile nice 98 was 55 person I don't
know it was but it was an older car
wasn't brand known real old so I was in
the led doing something by my house in
Chicago doing something this guy come
walking down the alley
yeah a fedora I'm like this who's tall
and skinny we refer to him in lady here
says mopey Jesus that's what we've named
the mopey Jesus his name was Bob Sproat
ad and they stopped and he's talking to
me and he's got a wad of money show me
as money that's where you get all that
money and he said you want to make money
like me I'll show you
he's I need a guy with a car he says I I
said what do you do as I stick up the
average steak up terror what did I know
I stick up Terence yeah he says
I'm gonna start doing banks I said I
wanna go back you want to come with me I
said I'll give it a try but I wear these
glasses I had thick glasses now he
should take him off I said I don't know
it places our dark at night I give it a
shot
so I met him and we went on our first
tab Rijn ice yeah it was a [ __ ]
nightmare it was so dark in there I
couldn't see he went in there any shot
he blew off the bottles off the black
bar you know if the back end in a bar
everybody hit the ground like they were
supposed to I'm yelling to start I can't
see in there I'm yelling to this image
it was a top coat in the hand
get down and I'm yelling get down about
so he yelling it yeah jag off the one
who laid on over there Bob's laughing he
goes over and it's it's it was that
correct coming and they had was sitting
I do it atop them and it's dark in there
I'm dolly I could see it you just saw so
to say I had bad dition yeah so if we
laughed all the way to the car and he
said I don't if you ever tell anybody
about this I get you I don't and then
from there I didn't go with him too
often cuz he was little while and then I
hooked up with two other guys Richard
Garmin and Bali Shiro and we start the
ng no chip guy Gino Chiappetta
and we started we did a couple taverns
one was at Cicero should have never went
there at shootout and it was a bad shoot
off we had a way but one of the bolts
went sure to windchill and parted my
partner Sarah Jean on Chiappetta
left the part on senators are legitimate
so he stats it but I'm the way we caught
a rumble from the cops somewhere when we
got closer to Chicago we had changed the
license plate siren and it became a
shirt on in the car shooting back and
forth we got away but in that shootout
we passed
Tony splasher was on the street of
sights
where you lived and he was in the car
talking a couple of his buddies and we
gotten back from because he was blocking
a street we were being chased and then I
start Boulevard move I had to [ __ ]
waver young I didn't know if Donnie was
in the car
except Tony knew something was up and he
told him Lord
these guys are whoever they're they're
being chased they pull over hit the car
sure couple shots got away got rid of
the guns that are in the car
see Tony - following dangerous thank you
I said Jack he's what that I shall be
stuck up some Tavern in Cicero
he says there's an easier way to make
money
I saw his bankroll I say just thinking
of no banks no stick-up no bangs
he said you grab the carrier
he stay going and they get money and
then they bring her back to the business
he's I'm doing it right now with Turk he
was with 3000 back then that's a lot of
damn little sizes he says that you could
go with us not that nice
all right so I got my two partners the
guys I mentioned previously my genome
Pauly and Richard Garmin
so he just when I had the bankroll and
grab a few dollars people are creatures
of habit they do the same damn thing
every day if they're you know they go to
the same stores they go to the same
banks they go to her same businesses so
we felt there very easy a couple of cars
- guys stick them up in the car we used
to drive right on the street walking out
of the bank
you know 20,000 15,000 so I had a money
back then a lot of money now it's like
twenty dollars twenty thousand right so
he grabbed these people so then we were
getting bigger and bigger making bigger
and bigger money but we went and he
stopped doing them bank robberies
because they would start laying traps
for you so we did when it was
that was the last one and don't we that
said we won't do no more just a cops are
wait for you and then once you either
gonna catch it any old cameras like they
got no so then we started doing
burglaries house burglaries but there
was all tips everything we got was
inside information and then I went to
jail should think I went to jail for him
but I got at a jail I was 19 I went in a
1959 I believe got on 60 was only a year
was the House of Corrections I headed
I had a felony reduced to a misdemeanor
that's why was two times had him read
those money you could always pay off the
judges say get out 20 visits me you know
hey how you doing right they did like
come on signer and he said I got a good
score for you and take the Richard
garment he says the jeweler building I
swears that he's the mauler building
Donna Wabash Tariq I know we're gonna
rob that John I said that's all villains
full of jeweler's yeah they got crash
gates that come down everything if the
alarm goes up can't get mad at her so he
says there's gonna be a New York jeweler
gonna be in there
you and Richard get a room at the Palmer
House somebody'll call you and that
jeweler is in the that New York jeweler
is with the two jewelers that own the
jewelry company there I saw that easy
enough so Richard and I couple things
with that
we parked our car in forest fire jumped
a DL and it take you right down the
freeway and we're going Marshall Field's
in the basement we walk up the stairs go
over to the Palmer House which was then
and get a room we lay in the room until
the phone ring when the phone rang and
the guide said where your package didn't
come mr. Thurman that means the jailer
wasn't there so I think the second or
third time we get that call and said
your packages arrived so we put our top
coats on or Ford ours but the 45s in the
briefcase went across the street because
the modern polling was right across the
street from the L which was in a
basement you know as subway I should say
so he took the we took the elevator up
to the third floor walked two flights up
took the elevator up another flight then
walked up another flight show in case
they had any cameras then we walked into
the it wasn't like the reception area
and we side by side think he knocked
down a ton of people got looked down he
showed a card investigating we
understand there's gonna do you have a
problem over and the guy open up the
dark so he opened up the door we running
there was two brothers jewelers there
was a Jewish guy Zimmermann I think
their name was I'm not sure and the New
York jeweler so we got him we taped him
up and I noticed the windows ro blinds
so I closed the blanks and I got her to
safe well he's going through their
pockets there's a bag a post this big he
got he said added sizes camara he comes
over us [ __ ] safes open there's
nothing in the safe he went you weren't
like that he picked up on it before I
did was an in st. Jack the jeweler's
clean not too safe when he's seen is
safe to give
they can bridge that come together I
said oh he's [ __ ] that I went
like that so I got all this [ __ ] yeah
and it to Vicki and he says I'm gonna go
down oh I'm gonna wait petiole for you I
waited five 10 minutes with these guys
in the room now when I was sure he was
out of the building
then I went down same routine elevator
or a walk two flights not an elevator
walk the flight
elevator right because them gates come
down these guys scream robbery boom the
gates come on yank on the whole things
done sigh going on I meet him at the
subway we jump at the elbow we've got a
forest part we go to me and I am road
where Tony splasher was in a motel room
with this guy Mike waiting for us to
come back with with the goods because he
was gonna pass they Anna we hand him the
stuff but had to weigh their first we're
checking out the pouch and they're all
in blue Steinman's and and the wax paper
I think he says man he's we're getting
less money than we should he should look
at this I love this old Lionel whose
diamonds I mean you're taking Abbas this
big full of documents and I don't want
to mean how much money we get because
I'm embarrassed but I trust that my
front doning right
why the best Tony and Mike and the
outfit made most of the money so we got
rid of him we went back 51 this place I
went to the launch and on what part
there was a lounge and we were watching
the news guys and it comes over the air
comes over the air right after the
robbery not some a matter of two hours
big you call it $500,000
that's the biggest driver in Chicago
straight the back look I don't say 9
everybody's gone bad guys really got
lucky well know where they where I'm
sitting right what I can get never
though of me right three days later I
get pulled over by the detectives they
says Hanna wants to talk to Hanna or
what's the charge of robbery you know I
said I'd like to see my mommy you know
so I go downtown
I go to where's the name it was a police
station they came and thinking of me
about Shakespeare so I go and I go up
his office
they take the cuffs off he says you want
some coffee or a doughnut seriously I
think it's not what do you want woody
what's up
he said never [ __ ] belief in the
millionaire's what what are you talking
about I said what do you owe I'm here
for this you [ __ ] did that robbery
the mauler blowing ice what are you
talking about Isis what Muller Billy
what robbery he's a known you've done
that's like a robbery he said Jordan
pinky Gorman I said you got the wrong
information
so I can't prove it is that just what
you don't know and I you could go I
didn't know I did then that Hannah was
our ring under control by the Chicago
Outfit so when in a moose party guys
have probably told his [ __ ] cop so you
see I mean they loose mulch loose lips
sink ships so that's what happened yeah
that was there was a big one then I did
Brinks trucks and all of that what was
the one in the you're famous for turned
down in Calumet City Indiana though
autumn the brain at the bank fault
yeah they call yeah I'm a kid still very
young kid in the 50s
Tony comes to me and he says
listen I got a story says with three
guys that you don't know but I know and
I think he and you will be together he
says we're gonna do it together is gonna
be six of us at bank banks banks car I
said here we go at the banks again he's
no no no we're gonna we're gonna gone to
the vault
it's a new experience yes all right so I
I get me one of the guys so was there a
sandwich Joe Lombardo not be known to me
that in later years Joe Lombardo would
become our boss
he was just right then and there Joe's
working as a work to crap games gambling
in Chicago and he's got his through
fronts I don't even know they hired
don't even know the flick of names there
I don't even though I think care so we
all take a ride to 600 us we go to
Calumet City and I see a the bank and
then I see an empty building next third
right outdoor they got two foundations
you start building something we go
through the foundation double foundation
which should make it that big ice melt
would be thinking a week over there
anything to get your that he said what
we're getting the empty building we've
got out of the basement so we figured
out we got Rick foundations then we know
how many we mark walked off the footage
from one foundation to the bank vault
because the bank had a basement though
so we walked it off and come right up
underneath the ball
we had underneath the vault today at a
robbery not that day-to-day at a robbery
we come equipped with two cars radios
and all the tools we knew we couldn't
smoke we couldn't eat we couldn't piss
because DNA you know we thought they
could get that stuff that we thought
that stuff before they made it known so
we did all of that and it was a lot of
work a lot of work I mean the hard part
was going to the floor
from the base we got concrete rebar very
yeah with rebar and we had torches and
tanks are very very difficult and
finally we get up in there we had a
little ladder with us and we got up in
there how many hours of this take full
day a full day to go to but I'm
exhausted
we're a dirty and exhausted by the time
we got in there and we didn't have hip
to date tools to open up the boxes that
because there's double locks but we
managed to open them we use the crowbars
and hammers and chisels and sludges we
packed them open we're going for the
bigger boxes the bigger box anything
that was paper useless thus we should've
left it there
we took the jewelry in cash and then at
the end of the day we wound up with
750,000 cash and valued valued it and
probably a million dollars in jewelry
but you don't get that either you get a
quarter you know whatever the prices on
jewelry so then I come to find out the
off it gets 20% one of the guys they
want to pay I don't know what happened
them but we all paid 20% so I wind up
with 50g 50g and a Josephine dinner yeah
it took us a day to count the money we
brought her up to this guy's house the
one that didn't want to give 20% and it
was like a full size bed now remember we
got singles $5 bills twenties hundreds
and we're putting them at thousand
dollar wrappers they covered the bed
foot honey that's some money with Sunday
about a foot high our hands were totally
green from counting the money
totally very mink and then
we took our rents out and we left out of
they kind of had his windows blocked off
boarded up his wife couldn't go in the
room she put a padlock on the door and
it was a good feeling having that kind
of my bro I immediately want to bought a
new car but no curse every time he did
something I had a reputation as a car
buff people would say your ashtrays full
of cigarettes just sell it tomorrow it's
all tonight sign my car street for cars
here easy I like cars just don't like as
you could see yeah
what so do you never got caught for that
never you never did time for that
you never got caught huh I get the 1
Brinks truck that I wrote about five or
six years later I gave roll in the case
became a witness trial so you got away
with that except for that I spent the
money was 366,000 these are these are
big big scars you stories of it Derek
then another when I did by myself Brinks
truck and I didn't have to know my
papers that and but I did give the gay
20% that give me a tip and what he did
was this case grandfather honk I forgot
worked at this warehouse where all these
armored car trucks was pulling at the
end of the day well I don't have enough
time
to go to the bank and drop the money
that they collected all day so they pull
it in the garage the truck and then hang
the keys up on a pegboard
and then the old man who was a janitor
in there was kids grandfather or uncle
sweep any scene though you know what's
going on watch the choice so the kid
told me see my grandfather wise dalam I
said to look for a two-man truck it's
got to be a two-minute truck as they're
open all the way through and if he sees
one come to get the key tell him I want
to keep I want the number to chart and
we need four spots that gets it all
settled where he knows he's got it I'll
meet him that night I'll go by the side
door but a building I'll knock kind of
dark three times tap another retreat
that he can hand me the key
he'll hand me the key and I'll give it
them back in an hour so he did it the
Amity key and I made it wax impression
Iowa and I had a key gun in the car I
put some stuff in her to make it hard in
a meeting I made a key I copy the key
yeah so then I went back and I gave the
original key back and not gonna thaw
reopen up lohan I never seen this bad
thing so for about a week straight I
followed that truck every morning they
left there to see if they kept on going
to the last stop and it wasn't
Shamburger and they stopped their last
stop and I go have dinner they go in
there to to to enough cops Brinks
drivers so I said it's gonna work
they're right on time creatures of habit
that's the wrong so they went in there I
went to bed
dirty truck open up the dining head
there cap on ain't no no grey shirt open
up the door bridge stenograph tree bags
pull them out I didn't like the dark I
knew it I was doing I didn't like the
dark because I ain't no in there they're
gonna be missing these bags they could
say they fell out the back door this
wasn't in in st. John so I just push the
dark clothes true the bags in the car
were carnal to God then I cut him okay I
went over 90000 by myself 90,000 I have
kicked no money hard bags open up there
man they're like man I mean the real
hard bags open I had come over and the
next day was on the news that some bags
fell out of a truck yeah and they would
appreciate it there was a reward if they
were returned they started laughing yeah
so all the guys just a man I wish out to
see that money laying in the street
I slept so I never talked about that at
some point you kind of you got into
being a hit man well at some point you
got into being a hit man for the for the
Chicago yeah yeah can you talk like
Sherman Wisner was one of the people you
sure won him Jerry I come Jerry Lisner
Sherman that's his name I called Jerry
mm-hmm
it was a I don't know what would you
call a guy in it would kind your parents
at her in her life savings he'd be from
a front he would be front of my other
life savings and then they'd be nice
said so this I didn't know it at the
time so the sky introduce them to me and
I talked them and I didn't like him he
was a weasel type guy you know but every
time I bump into the gate I always close
you up to me
get the [ __ ] out here so I have a drink
and he'd have his old lady with him you
know big tall blonde with a boob job
shoes
beastly so that was as far as my
friendship one with this guy know he
gets busted
I guess in Washington DC because if you
go in front of a federal grand jury in
Washington DC that means that you
probably did whatever you did wrong and
watch them in DC I don't know he's going
in front of a grand jury
I have no idea one day Tony calls me and
he said Joe Pickman telling wants to
talk to us he's got some important news
that dollars I said what is it he said
we I couldn't talk to my new phone so he
meet Joe Pickman Tully
i jumping the deli on the restaurant in
Las Vegas this is where this took place
it was called Villa d'Este
the legitimate owner the place was Sam
Giancana mo he owned the property in the
business and he did it he put it up
because he likes his own Russian
obsesses way he was and Joe big Nutella
he was the driver safe but everything on
there Joe slang
everything was done in Joe's name so
don't even go meet Joe pig and I called
Joe Pig say societies television telling
us he says there was a lawyer in there
that has a claim and he said that his
plan was that's the fame on two guys in
Nevada a money-laundering scheme
something like that and he said I asked
them where the guys were and he said
Frank colliding and Tony's slideshow and
the lawyer says Vietnam II Justin I know
Josiah or so you continued document
again then a guy left the lair low so
Joe said he said he's testifying on you
guys in front of a federal grand jury
says we're walking out of the place the
right no we don't say in front of joke
big so we walked out of the place he
said he gotta kill him now you gotta
whack him how's that realize that nice
but I could tell you this my stone
they're gonna kill me in front of the
grand jury before that we I get the
opportunity
sure [ __ ] the next day knocking on my
door I open up the door I knew they were
there I seen him true people they didn't
I
they put their thumb up but I guess so I
opened up the door and he slapped me in
a chest with a subpoena to appear in
front of a federal grand jury in DC so I
said okay so now I gotta get a lawyer a
way are out there in Virginia say go to
the yellow pages and I get a letter like
I don't want no lawyers in Virginia and
I got a la guy lucky got a good lawyer
he didn't charge me a lot of money so I
flew out there to meet the lawyer to go
to court first time I met him we took
they got some kind of an owl or a train
system that brings you right there we go
there and they go in a room to strike
first attorneys in there with a couple
FBI agents they're asking me questions
I'm lying bland like something up there
satisfied with mental lives they put me
up in front of the grand jury
I give him custom Oni I like I created
stories like you can't imagine I know
where he came from but I created it I
get off the stand there up please now
maybe they were pleased because they
knew different they were going to
me for lying hello so when I get back to
Vegas Tony's what'd you say so I lied
that what am I gonna say I stupid your
dad art of it they call a new they call
everybody else they not called it Daria
you know unless they want to put you in
jail for 18 months because they know
you're to think the fifth
he's one night you gotta hurry up and
kill this [ __ ] so we close by
saying what's the matter why is it
taking so long you want me to do it hey
sis you ain't gonna do not know more
Tony you know that you're talking [ __ ] I
just give me a little time I saw I got
to get a guy he's not bringing them in
with you whatever you do don't bring
Newman
I said why see cuz oh if they got Birds
dogs cats and kids he'll kill everything
in the house I say I don't bring him so
I did mention that the boom and he's I
wish his wife's there meaning Jerry's
way pop killer I see can he go Tony Tony
don't whine jitter so I got somebody
else and I killed a guy kill him in his
own how'd that go down well the guy came
to Vegas the hit man the other it man
and I just when he got to my place we
got to my place I called Tony's I mean
it called Jerry listeners house and I
said we became friends though we weren't
getting the log of the pit I saw you
doing Jarius I got somebody who could
rip off we can make some wedding on oh
come on
overrides not going over there unless
you got your if your wife's throwing
kids ain't coming over another night or
nobody's there
you sure yeah I'm positive just happened
to be out of work hurt charlie to use
the do chrome crimson the fictitious
Leon you know yeah register I should say
grab the car put the guns in there
I can't work gloves one gun police radio
I can't ever walked
like an Internet so the guy is gonna be
any carelessness that a police radio and
he's got all these stuff that we're
gonna get rid of after I killed this
listener yet so I go up to the Darby
being I knocked a couple of times I
dreamed that Boehner way try to wipe
over my palm because I can't work gloves
because you'd notice the right away he
opens up the Doris I look to the right I
look up the stairway I'm listening sis
your wife ain't on my kids it on you
sure yeah I really school in the act cuz
I don't want to talk he turns her on
boom boom boom I shoot him gonna back it
up five times real quick baby made me be
me he runs he looks at me why are you
doing in I'm thinking this guy should be
dead I was told to kill this guy with a
22 and use half loads from Tony I did
that it was like shoot him in air what
he kept gun pellet gun
he runs a chase him when he gets into
the kitchen/dining area
the garage doors there leading into the
garage he hits the garage door button to
open up their overhead door I hear the
door going up and I hit it and it stops
the door stopped the door maybe two feet
three feet meanwhile he's down on the
ground between my legs
he's bleeding all over the place and I
gotta finish
cuz no way I could leave him not there's
just no way you leave it you this far
into it say rip the cord added a water
machine they tied around his neck and I
pull it in the breaks that's this guy's
not supposed to die sonne I reach over I
reach over and I grab dad nice and
compact boards they put him in the
kitchen every sober and I grabbed it
he stole her it just says I'm ready to
come down
man that little bright star opens and
I'm not gonna whoever it is I gotta kill
I don't want it but I gotta what am I
gonna do so I go like this it's it's the
guy my Burton calm
oh Jesus scared the [ __ ] out of me
he said counted the shots he says he
said come on I was worried I secured a
on the radio no nothing
he says none of the neighbors called he
sat brought extra bullets in it
deflected ain't gonna believe it so I
faked him I take the Schultz up through
my pocket reload it he puts the plug
back but said I put one in front and I
ain't good to boy on and the frontal
part of his fat the bullets up then I
said come on what trohman to pull why he
said now look the edge at all
Isis I got blood all over me Isis I got
from the gun the powder come on you do
come on come on drag him to trauma the
poor we going to pull up their necks the
guy goes to the water and he sinks we
leave that was a got rid of all this
stuff came back to my place in our
underwear rode back in her indoors and
then we took a shower my hands get that
[ __ ] off from the pole and case there
was any remnants at a gun powder in here
soda tea later and then I drove to the
airport Neill of so so when you get an
order from when you get an order from
like Tony here from somebody like that
to hit somebody gotta get it okay
is it is it something you get paid for
or is it just something you just do
whenever you're ordered to do some when
I hear people say you get paid for this
[ __ ] there's no paycheck for killing
everybody if they already to kill
somebody whoever orders you that's a
boss you know that they got the OK to to
tell you to do it it goes in front of to
retreat bosses and they decide if it's a
right
for you to kill whoever you're gonna
kill or they come up here and tell you I
listen you got to take care of so and so
you don't question it
you'll do it if you don't then you
become the victim because they're not
gonna come to you if it ain't think you
would say you were gonna say no so
that's the process pretty ever so when I
kill him
listener I did ask Tony did you get okay
anis he said yes but he done he like I
found that out later
did you ever get convicted of murder did
I yeah I got immunity from prosecution
which is how are you able to talk here
yeah I got a munities from prosecution
as long as I cooperated with the
government yeah we're getting to that I
could freely talk about stuff like that
or else I wouldn't talk about I'm not
bragging about it sergeant of all you
don't brag about stuff like that
it was it's not nice it's not right but
it's no different I saying people some
people say why could you put a
comparative - it's no different than
being in a military and killing a lot of
people that you don't even see you can
give it an order - no I said you know do
you I mean - do you have like memories
of these murders or their psychological
repercussions later on or do you sleep
at night or anything like that I do not
have any repercussions and thought their
memory about people I killed because I
would why I'd be in a straightjacket
this is something you washed out of your
mind you have to do it and that's
something I've done if you can I'd that
story it is you just yeah get it out of
your head I think it takes a certain
personality type certain series of
traits to be a love you have to be to
start with a little strong strong
character strong inside a willpower to
forget you know to try and forget I done
do anything I remember this nonsense is
when I
interviewed about it otherwise I'd never
talk about it never break it when it
comes in it's nothing to brag about
so Tony Tony Spilotro continues to move
on right
oh yeah man why he was the boss honor
yeah
Vegas Tony was the boss I was his
underboss who's he to Boston Chicago
when he left or he was the boss in
Chicago but if he went back there to be
a boss you gotta remember saw if you're
not in the state that you're a boss in
and you're in another state you don't
control that state anymore then they
know get it we'll take it over if you
come back you may jump into that
position again
whatever territory you had it's so he
couldn't be a boss in Chicago excuse me
yeah so how did you relationship with
Tony change over the years because you
started off Tony was getting mark
paranoid mark barnard everything and I
just see it as a very obvious and but
yet he always was in the limelight he
managed to keep himself in the limelight
he'd always come to my restaurant cost
me a lot of heat coming to the
restaurant all the time he cost me oh
let's see trying to do a legitimate
business so he start getting more
paranoid more paranoid and I think I
gotta slow down
Tony what do you mean I said I could see
it's getting wholly at all this news and
all that he's relaying I said of course
they're lying on a lot of things ice
ignorin hey sir you know I [ __ ] RICO
law they could put you in jail for every
Cola
they can lie all they want they put you
in a newspaper they show association put
you job for 20 years but she hit a point
you know so I start noticing more and
more Tony was falling into more involved
with his family his wife and his kid he
was becoming a guy that I felt didn't
want to go to jail
want her to become a family man stay at
home he's not in Chicago not that his
next step I thought would be leave agus
let somebody else come modern beat a
boss or try to leave Vegas he want to
start a new life I know cuz he's saying
I'm fed up with this [ __ ] I'm fed up
with it and he was happy to you know
have a son and a wife so I always got a
strange feeling side of that when he was
filling out and I don't know what his
plans were I'll leave that up to your
audience to figure it out but I could
see he was getting a little tired of
fighting to police the newspapers and he
wasn't gonna run anywhere he wasn't
gonna run away in other where it's
disappeared if he had a case gone he
wouldn't do that because of his family
he loved him too much he wasn't gonna
leave because if you leave and go to
Hong Kong or wherever you run through
they'll get you eventually I'll get you
defensive get you somewhere along the
line they get don't forget they got me
needs a maze of dollars they get from
the taxpayer thanks people the taxpayers
I should say to go after you so he knew
that
so Tony would never run nor would his
brother that's the way it is and then
eventually something came up where he
put a hit out on you right
hey there well he he there was a hit you
were in prison but that you heard a
recording yeah I was pulled into an
interview room I was found guilty on the
case and I was pulling down every roll
by
a couple agents and they told me that
there was a contract on my life and I
don't get the [ __ ] outta cuz I know it a
game they played it scam they all played
again whether they're agents or regular
locals they have to do it he said my
responsibility is a federal agent to a
form unit there's a contract that any
like I said get the [ __ ] out of here and
I told the cops sue me down to my salt
so they bring me down yes if you're not
bringing me to they having a Dom Atari
you're putting me in as Sally's because
there's a kind of track down in your
life at the fact then different radio
comes at bringing back upstairs I think
again I go back upstairs
they got this recorded a why when you
hear some message this is where Deb's
say listen throw where at that and I
hear one game yet around this and what's
going on out there in Vegas Tony said I
can't control this guy he's like a loose
cannon
meaning me city agent says what did you
hear who did you throw you're listenin
to is I'm not ready to talk to you about
it at say stands they're silent and then
a guy says well who's the novel whose
whacking people and all I'm robberies
he's just a better guy I'm telling him I
can't control him he says he's got a
tough crew guys that are with him is
there anything I think they may take it
over take me out you know any guys guys
well then you know what you got to do
he's gonna make buying this thing he
shall get an appeal bond he says then
you gotta clean your dirty larger well
[ __ ] let me tell you something I've had
39 fronts of my lifetime maybe more they
were killed by the outfit I didn't want
to beat 39 or 40 so I went back down to
the Sun I thought about it overnight got
up in the morning and I told get all of
that agent that was there I want to I
just get all it at agent I want to talk
to but this is this is the recording was
Tony yeah it's Tony and this is somebody
that you've been tight with her
we were 12 here so I'm how many years I
was 48 or 49 when I roll I think but you
were very you were very close
points when he games don't I heard them
said it my ice thorough water you know I
broke my heart I don't give a [ __ ] about
gel gel it's just an inconvenience guys
like us make it in there it's not some
place you look to go to relish the
thought oh I can't wait to go if you
could avoid it of course you're gonna
avoid it but they hear this guy to talk
about wanting to kill me I have him to
kill me and taking all the weight off
himself and pushing on me it bothered me
troubling me deeply but it took a lot
for me to become a witness I wasn't
raised this way
it took me 25 years to get over the fact
that I was a witness 25 years I hated
myself
25 I am [ __ ] nobody but then I
became actually I'm a religious guy now
I really am and I all these things are
bi Amy and I did the right thing he was
dishonorable to me I would have probably
got killed in jail or on the street so
either way I made the right choice it
was difficult for me to also become a
witness because of my mother and my
family my sister and brother you know I
don't want him to be disgraced
they'd have to live with that because
they're still living in that area or
were living in that area but time goes
by and time heals all yeah it does 25
years later I could go back to that city
I thought I was back there recently I
could go anywhere I want nobody bothers
me they understand they understand why I
roll they didn't like it at first they
were very mad they said why would he do
that
meaning me somebody had a [ __ ] morale
pretty good
for him to do cuz he's a stand-up guy to
refer to me what the [ __ ] did they refer
to Tony as the little guy
what the devil guy do Tom they were
starting to dislike Tony a lot because
of his brother the tool and that's it
yeah well that's the ultimate [ __ ]
around isn't it
I can't hear you that's the ultimate
[ __ ] around isn't it somebody's [ __ ]
they're trying to kill you no I mean
like I said
39:40 guys enter or wept thinking well
I'm gonna be alright
being an adult to me they like me too
much your best friend preaching it at
gallows boo that's it yeah okay
so Tony what happened to him exactly he
mmm what happened to Tony eventually the
Tony was eventually you live by the
sword you die by the sword
eventually Tony was murdered and I told
I got a call what's under witness
protection program and FBI guys they was
Dennis thermally he said to me joining
his brother Michael disappeared he said
where did he run to I stay in Tehran
anywhere he's not here nor that I say no
Tony they're dead he said he i sat on
I'm felling it her dead Tony's not gonna
run I'm on the telephone I'm a Mobile
Alabama his agents calling me from Vegas
that's what that's what your witness
well they stare was at one of the first
spots and yeah and he says well I'll get
back to you in a couple days a couple
days later you have to get back to me
with sound of news that they discovered
the bodies in a cornfield and he said
he's 40 suppose they were killed they
have dust in their lungs ice they
weren't killing no car
nice because they got Dustin or like
pragmatic children they're that dirt
flow up in her mouth nice they were
killing a their Cicero for Bensenville
eventually you'll find on and I was
right they were killed impossible in a
basement he said well they were beaten
at that that tells you right dad there
it was in a residential area I'm Phyllis
agent this was residential they can't
use a gun they could use knifes they
could choke I think it kicked come take
a beat him he said well there's no
physical marks and bruises all over her
faces about then they beat him with the
metal bats or they kicked them and they
punch them whatever but they beat him to
death I didn't like the idea that but I
don't like you know have bothered me or
other bother me that they were killed
like that that fashion but I didn't
understand why because they couldn't
make shooter
so when a hit is put out on somebody is
it typically guns knives baseball bats
what's whatever you choose the door
whatever it calls for in that area
whatever works yeah if you choose that
you could use the 45 years of 45 years
of 20 to 30 years of 20 though you got
to use the knife you got to use the
night whatever the situation calls from
we're getting used inot might use
dynamite Brigid Cara whatever it is so
what do you think that I mean I'm trying
to get a handle on the psychological
traits if somebody that has a life of
crime as opposed to like say just a
regular law-abiding good making a mole
yeah you know I respect people that and
I'm not [ __ ] any is right now I
respect a man that works from 9:00 to
5:00
they make good money and they save money
this is the life they choose to live and
God bless him for I choose to life hi
wanted to live is because I found that
glamorous I did find out that money
don't last long because easy it's not
easy come Peter but I'm gonna use that
term easy come easy go you got to
remember we're up 24 hours a day
thinking and robbing business Kate or
gotta works for a living
he's sleeping eight nine hours we're out
there spending money so yeah most County
said where any outfit that broke died
busted I'm not I'm not even going to
that list there's only a few that had a
lot of money at then only a few spent
money got too many hours
I respect the working class people alive
now some of these white-collar crimes
another star biggest crooks our world
let's go to Washington DC I don't want
to get the politics but there are
criminals
Republicans and Democrats alike big
liars
oh we were seats compared to these
people the only thing is they didn't
kill people but they kill them another
way anyway I thought I'd wrote in it
thank you very much for talking to me no
problem your stories are amazing thank
you thank you